yeah oh
did you just snort i know why you left
i know how you left because you took one
look at them you're like
i know who the beast
oh you know how there's like a saying
where it's like
[Music]
you know you know
you know how there's a saying where they
go how can you tell someone's a vegan
and they're like don't worry they'll
tell you i feel like this is
another alternative version was like how
do you know someone's a vegan oh you'll
see
that's exactly yo it would
blow my mind if you said yeah
i eat meat can i have all of my vegans
go into that pool of light and my
non-vegans in that pool of life
the more education that we can put out
there just like stuff like this is
beautiful that's what i was most anxious
about is learning more of what i'm
trying to step
into i don't know if i'll ever give up
chicken
i'm just gonna be honest with you i
don't know
[Laughter]
[Music]
i know you guys record for an hour for
you to guys keep this
do you know they were laughing on the
edits like the black guy said chicken we
gotta keep it in
yeah but i really wish you were to say
watermelon and purple drink
it's okay chicken will do oh i can't get
mad at him because he said it but damn
you said it i want to eat a lot cleaner
chicken
you know i want to eat a lot of cleaner
chicken you know wash a chicken
and you can just tell at the beginning
of her speech at his speech the girl's
looking like
i'd tyrone
[Applause]
and then at the end of it she's like
tyrone you're problematic
i believe that humans are the top of the
food chain is a human
at the same level of equivalence is like
a fish
right there's probably a big reason why
i'm not vegan anymore you know
why should we have a pet that's a dog
rather than eat the dog
and i think the most important question
is why should i
love my neighbor rather than eat my
neighbor
what the [ __ ] did you say run that back
and it gets into moral questions like
you know why should we have a pet that's
a dog
rather than eat the dog and i think the
most important question is
why should i love my neighbor rather
than eat my neighbor
are we the dumb ones
i just don't see it like i don't even
see like what is like a food chain you
know what i'm saying that's just some
contract some guy made and put a little
diagram and put us
human beings in the top so you don't
think there's a food chain in the animal
kingdom
where one animal eats one animal when it
eats the other one yes there's a
hierarchy in the
some people refute what is man-made or
man
thought because a man thought of it
that's how little they think of me it
comes to the discussion that we
were saying like when a white person is
like yo white people
and a man is like yo man or the word
this is a bit of the same it's like
no animals are equal to us and
at men are the worst it's just because
some they belittle
everything there is a food chain yeah
listen it's the equivalent of saying
there are no social classes in society
that's just some made-up theory
that some guy no some people are richer
and some people live in better lives
there's a class i don't think it's a
question of whether we're at the top i
think it's a question of
what do you do with that if you have
a more conscious energy than an animal
what do you do with that power
do you choose to take a life or do you
choose to live in
love okay listen you know what you gave
jubilee priests last video i'm gonna
knock them
they always seem to choose the most
ridiculous looking vegans i know vegans
personally
and they're really cool and normal
people then that wouldn't be vegan
yeah so i have no idea why they choose
these fringe weirdos
why do they all dress i know vegans you
wouldn't be able to tell vegan by
looking at them
then that wouldn't be vegan these people
came dressed
like they're part of a circus i think
it's really powerful no matter what
you're eating
to put your intentions into whether it's
prayer in vocation and it's just such
great power and presence versus just
like scarving something down but like
can i just really be present with this
meal take my time and chew it slowly
so that's the first thing i resonate
with and what i choose to do
it's not because you're vegan or even
vegetarian vegetarian
that's your healthy okay i feel like if
the meat eaters
they're like yeah you know what
processed food and stuff like that
there's processed food in veganism
there's processed food in vision
it's not because you're vegetarian or
vegan that's your healthier
or you don't have any processed food
processed food is found in
both those sides so i just want to make
that clear i don't want to just want to
make a point of that
i would kill an animal
you guys all better come forward if you
go eat it you got to be ready to kill it
too
i'm not saying that you should be out
there killing it but if someone said hey
for today's meat you have to kill it and
you
now i could never do that boo boo you
indirectly support it so if you
indirectly support it you should be able
to directly support it so
your hypocrite basically i think there'd
be tons of context where i'd kill an
animal like if
if a lion's gonna go kill a baby i'd
probably kill an animal
i'd kill an animal to save a human life
and i get the vegans probably wouldn't
do that
i would i would because
careful they come in trigger why do you
run like that because they're triggered
and that's what we do when we're
triggered we're just saying man did a
sandal shuffle
why is it always the extreme case when
talking about would i kill an animal
like
exactly if you were in this city there
aren't lions running around downtown l.a
to be afraid of the vegans
they're right that is a stupid example
yeah when they ask the question you
should go to an extreme you should use
everyday life so if for example
i raise an animal in the wild it's like
an animal i've built a relationship with
and that animal now why is it
[Music]
always
are human beings animals yes yes sure
would you kill another human being to
save another human being yes
yes yeah yeah if someone's attacking
somebody i would probably kill them to
save the other one that's not
complicated
either way someone's gonna die from a
dying and i'd rather kill the person
who's attacking another random human
because they might attack me afterwards
what makes one person more valuable to
another is it your relationship to that
person
it would yeah it would probably be so if
for example
i raise an animal in the wild this guy's
doing a false equivalency
your animal is not a human stop
comparing the two
they're not the same know where they
ever be your dog
is not the same as other human beings
your cat is not the same as other human
beings
another any other animal that you raise
is not i don't care if it's domesticated
or not
they are not humans i know this crazy
dog people out there be like my dog
deserve to live over
no okay if you're willing to eat animals
and you're fine with eating animals
dogs are no different i'm not saying i'm
gonna go and cut off a leg off
lassie or whatever okay final dog is not
getting put over
a stove it's not happening that being
said
you can't have this hierarchy of animals
where like dogs are more important
than cows no no they're all the same i'm
not a hypocritical meat-eater animal
okay because what you think is important
to you is irrelevant in other countries
or to other people and you eat cows
every day well in india they don't allow
people to eat cows should indians impose
their moral values on you no
you can't but then you want to look at
chinese people eating dogs you're like
that's unacceptable
if you eat animals you have no basis to
say
which animal deserves to live or doesn't
that's it
it's either all okay or none of it's
okay don't we love that line
yeah same here yeah the same thing i
hate that kind of
like to eat steak but you wouldn't eat
horse because you like horses and stuff
like that yo
eat it i don't care if you eat it eat it
eat it
i don't care i don't care if you don't
eat horse that's perfectly acceptable
but you don't get to impose that on
other people
does that make sense if you say i don't
feel comfortable with it that's okay
there's nothing wrong with that but you
shouldn't tell other people what they're
not allowed so when people go to china
but y'all can't eat these dogs
yes they can you see because it's about
relationships
you kill them a person over an animal
that's correct because i believe human
beings are animals
now i see humans at a different level
but maybe you value fish at the same
level as a person i
we see it very different i do you don't
i do
i do i do i think animals are like equal
to human beings i do and if i saw like
an animal fighting with a human in the
street
i would like look at the animal and be
like can i help you
and the animal wouldn't respond because
like i don't speak their language but
like
i feel what it's saying you know because
i operate on feelings
and i just we're all animals you know so
i'd be like hey human can you stop
and if the animal is biting the human's
neck mom just like nature you know
yeah it costs
more than it should to eat healthy
it's more expensive to eat healthy i
don't think it's too expensive
farmer's market is something that i'm
trying to frequent more
but sometimes you know you can go spend
here and definitely not get as much um i
definitely want to see that you know
maybe that'll encourage people to eat
a little healthier if you can go grab
that fresh fruit those fresh veggies
for five ten bucks you know i think uh
our culture
as a society is just in great towards
like the fast food culture which is
cheap and accessible
but now i think we have more of an
established
like medical basis on what's healthy and
what's not healthy
and to get that content and to have it
be tasty as well
is is expensive i'm running in i have so
much to say
oh your phantom
bag hates a strong word i really dislike
her
my disdain for her is rising i don't
know
vegans like that i don't know vegans
that are like that
they're going to run into some to be
like man guys
just say it relax here's the thing she's
gonna she's gonna say this from a place
of privilege i guarantee yeah
absolutely definitely it does not cost
more money to be vegan
that is a myth it takes planning
yes the convenience is less can you grab
a hamburger at mcdonald's
for sure for 99 cents but can't how much
lentils can you buy
the issue is capitalism like that is
what is keeping us where we are
it's not that humans are smarter and
they're going to come up with this
technology
their technology exists it is there we
can
feed so many people it is capitalism
and factory farming therefore it costs
more to eat healthy period
and if you are in a food desert it's
going to cost you more
like onion lentils if you don't have
lentils around you
[ __ ] nugget you won't find it and it's
going to be easier for you to go
through whatever color now i said what i
said
oh i shouldn't say nugget can i have a
six pack of [ __ ] nuggets
nuggets yeah with the sauce would you
like some chicken in that no just some
[ __ ]
yeah yeah and a lot of sauce dumb sauce
like no you don't you don't see it you
you don't see it because you don't get
to see it and that's fine that's
perfectly fine but don't
don't go ahead and say like hey guys
no there's other people in this [ __ ]
that's better than you let's be clear
if tomorrow everyone wanted to turn
vegan it would be impossible
we don't have the production for it we
don't have it would have to be phases it
would be a slow process to turn everyone
vegan and this is such a western idea
you can tell it's only for people who
live in very privileged places
because go to africa and try to tell
them that they can't eat their cows or
whatever you know that livestock is how
they eat for weeks on end like
you can't just go willy nilly and try to
expect everyone to change overnight
no they need those animals everybody
else you don't so when you sit there you
run in like
i've got the answers we have the
technology we have the capacity
we have the you have it in your
neighborhood because you live with
bougie-ass white people
who probably can't afford to be vegan
but a lot of people can't
a lot of people don't have the means and
a lot of people will never have the
means so be honest about this
conversation most these companies that
are selling us products that are
like food they don't give a [ __ ] about
you at all
period someone's sitting on the island
somewhere oh yeah like just stacking
bread
and they're probably fast food really
healthy food yeah they're probably
eating real good they're probably their
own products
they're not eating any of that have you
seen the guy who invented kombucha
have you seen some of the people who
invented a lot of those vegan options
they're eating really good too
and they're behaving just like cat
police like the rest of them well you
don't think capitalism is involved in
veganism
it's big business right now it's like
yoga yoga started off as a spiritual
practice
guess what now it's very capitalistic so
when you sit there and you act like
meteors are the only capitalists no no
boo-boo there's plenty of capitalists in
vegan world
and it's not necessarily always a bad
thing if you have a vegan product then
there's a label on it
and it's not free
guess how it's moving just
just guess you go to certain
neighborhoods certain areas you don't
see the same fast food you don't see the
same restaurants
and it's all for a reason accessibility
i mean yeah that's a good point it's
like they don't have why is there many
health food stores
in the hood like i can't like get an
option why is there liquor store
everywhere exactly and it's true it's
like
when you break it down there's like
malicious intent to deharmonize and like
lower the vibration of certain people
steve deharmonize and lower the
vibration of people
and i just feel like if we're able to
get more vegan stores within these
low-income people of color neighborhoods
what we could do
is just raise everyone's chakra levels
and then point where everything's going
to be aligned
and we're really going to feel a certain
level of balance within
our own consciousness we're really going
to be able to feel
our spirits rising and our our falling
moon
just come into alignment and you're just
going to feel a sense of
serenity and i think that's good i think
it's something that we all need
you know i just feel like the things
that we're putting into our body are
just like dead carcasses
and when you when you put that dead
thing in your
you're literally killing your own life
force that's why i just feel like if
we're able
if we're able okay if we're able
okay if we're able to just bring
everyone's vibrations to a standstill
and just leave it at a nice little um
we could really bring it all together
yeah
let's carry on in certain areas and it's
like that's a part of it too it's like
what am i contributing to
true i'll say this you know when i was
11 years old
my father passed away from his second
heart attack
he was diabetic he was pissing out of a
tube i watched him deteriorate my
youngest years of my life
for like years and years just
deteriorate taking pharmaceutical drugs
and just kind of basically dying slowly
shut up what about you
this guy's talking about his dad dying
in his experience my mom died too
nobody asked you it's not about
she to me i'd rather spend an extra
dollar and either organic or something
healthy now
and live longer than try to cut corners
when you know i'm with you like make the
choice now
instead of later look how she's cutting
him off because if
you guys we have four minutes left sorry
but we have four minutes i want to
she was eating buckets of ice cream when
she
passed away she died at 49 years old
wow now choose now
i just wonder do you think bro like bro
do you think like she's
operating on like a higher vibration
because like she couldn't feel like the
energy
that you were channeling out and she
just cut it she cut it like very
abruptly
she cut it like right there the same way
like god cut your dad's life short
she just came in there and cut your
conversation
is she operating on a higher vibration
do you guys
have like cheat days ever hell no
i am vegan 100
at the front line ethical reasons always
always always and that's why i don't
think in 24 years i've ever gone back
it was hard to try new things things i
didn't like
found tons of vegan food i was like oh
god what the [ __ ] you people eating
and then simultaneously realizing that
there was options you know there's
always choices and it's always choices
we make like you said
you may never give up meat um fully
but it's like you're making a choice
you're at least thinking for yourself
and making a decision and like
that's all you can ask people to do just
think for themselves
not vegan thank you well i stand is
simple
i think animals are beneath us and
therefore i have no problem with it
that's it i'm not gonna be a giant
hypocrite about it no i feel that way
about all the animals no
yeah it's the same thing i don't find
any animal special a dog is not gonna
sleep in my bed
no sleeping in my bed sleeping in my bed
it's not gonna happen yeah but listen
you know
i just think it's unfortunate that
jubilee gets these obnoxious vegans on
and not more reasonable well thought at
once
um but it does you know great uh if it
was not like that we wouldn't be able to
talk about it
actually no we would if they would put
better people there we would be able to
talk about it and have a really honest
conversation yeah now we don't really
have much i mean we have people that are
goofy and some some of them are
hypocrites but whatever on the bright
side none of them were as bad as aaron
so that's good how can you be
make the car yeah yeah where your
crisper ball at
there you go so anyways that's it for
today's video tell us what you guys
thought about this discussion
uh we want to hear your thoughts let us
know how much you love
chicken
[Music]
you